ils sont une centaine à manifester sur
le campus de l'université mcgill
le dernier épisode de violence au proche
orient a provoqué la mobilisation des
groupes pro-palestiniens qui accuse
israël de crimes de guerre et de
nettoyage ethnique la discrimination et
le racisme sont à l'oeuvre
cette jeune palestinienne né à nazareth
ce n'est pas nouveau mais ça atteint des
sommets inégalés
plus de 1500 étudiants et professeurs
ont signé une pétition pour réclamer que
l'université liquide ses investissements
dans certaines entreprises qui vont en
faire un israël et qu'elle définisse le
sionisme comme une idéologie raciste
dans sa politique d'inclusion le
sionisme et le mouvement politique et
religieux né à la fin du 19e siècle qui
vise l'établissement et la consolidation
d'un état juif en palestine entre que ce
serait des zones est et très contraire à
la définition de discrimination et du
racisme de ne pas inclure le sionisme
surtout étant donné les récentes
atrocités qu'ils ont commis par israël
le sionisme depuis le xixème siècle a
été un mouvement colonialiste qui voyait
les palestiniens comme un obstacle à
l'établissement d'un état mal gérées
majoritairement juive la demande des
pétitionnaires a été refusée par la
direction de l'université mcgill
l'établissement affirme que proscrire le
sionisme entrerait plutôt en
contradiction avec son engagement pour
l'équité et conclusion on s'attaque pas
à des politiques d'état ou à des actions
du gouvernement sur le campus un
regroupement d'étudiants juifs dénonce
le discours des groupes pro palestiniens
jugeant qu'il veut le diaboliser une
doctrine tout à fait légitime
ça veut tout simplement dire croire au
droit du peuple juif à son
autodétermination sur sa terre
ancestrale
donc en fait c'est tout simplement
quelque chose qui est au coeur de notre
identité et c'est pas un compatible ni
avec le la lutte pour les droits
palestiniens qui sont évidemment un
peuple réel avec des aspirations
légitimes aussi sur ce même territoire
jamais centre est blessé la cheffe du
département d'études juives de
l'université estime que les groupes qui
ont lancé la pétition calomnie et
ostracisés israël et les juifs avec les
bouder
quel serait le deviennent vulnérables et
que le juif de viande de nouveau une
minorité mais manquèrent vaisselle le
conflit israélo-palestinien et provoque
des tensions depuis longtemps dans les
universités les positions des deux camps
sont irréconciliables
à l'image du conflit qui fait rage
depuis des décennies ici olivier bachand
radio-canada à montréal
et